[Music]
you believe that there are only nine
days left until Christmas I can't I'm
still trying to find gifts for everyone
on my list I'm on your list right oh
yeah definitely
well I already did my shopping and I
decorated my tree and I hung my stocking
so the next thing on my Christmas to-do
list is to write a very important letter
[Music]
Christmas Time Is Here Again I've got my
paper and I've got my pen
I'm riding Santa with my special wish
but there's only one thing on my
Christmas list
bring me a true love
a beautiful new love don't need no
presents under my tree all I want is
someone who truly loves me
bring me a true love
a beautiful new love sprinkle your magic
into my life bring me a true love on
this later night oh
my gosh Merry Christmas Amber
Merry Christmas Amber's backup singers
Merry Christmas Santa did you get my
letter I sure did did you read it oh of
course yay so you're gonna bring me my
true love for Christmas no foreign
but I wrote it in the letter I saw that
and it said you want me to bring you
true love yeah so a man presumably yeah
yeah so you want me to leave a human man
at your house for Christmas
well I didn't say that you did say that
yeah I heard that too
what do you think I do exactly
you're a Santa Claus and you make
people's dreams come true yeah if their
dream is to get a PlayStation 5 not a
human person
I'm a tinkerer not a trafficker
how would that even work
did you want me to build a man from
scratching my shop in the North Pole no
oh so so you were thinking baby I just
scoop up a Drifter on the way over and
you guys would hit it off not exactly
well those are pretty much the only two
ways that could work out I mean he's
making some good points yeah when you
break it down like that asking Santa for
a true love is creepy
foreign
every year I get these insane requests
from pop singers saying Oh Santa all I
want for Christmas is for you to fix the
disaster that is my love life like what
I can't do that what do I look like
hitch
how am I supposed to find a long-lasting
relationship have you tried looking into
the mirror maybe the problem isn't the
men you're meeting maybe the problem is
you
better when you were only saying ooh and
ah
your backup singers are right Amber I
can't get you true love that's something
you'll find on your own if you're
willing to do some growth and
introspection hey yuck
is there anything else you want for
Christmas how about a PlayStation 5.
no way you needed to write that letter
back in June
how about a wooden fire truck fine
perfect a wooden fire truck it is have a
Merry Christmas everyone ho ho ho ho
so I don't know
you guys what do you think should we
finish this song yes and also you should
do some work on yourself
[Music]
a beautiful new love
[Music]
all right